En esas conversaciones, ella me dio confianza
al enfatizar la gran relación que tenía con cada uno de ellos,
y que podía hacerlo.
Sé que habrá muchas situaciones
donde desearía que ambos pudiéramos tomar decisiones juntos.
Siempre estuvimos muy sincronizados.
Me tomo el atrevimiento de sugerirles
a Uds. que hablen de ese tema ahora, cuando están sanos.
Les pido que no esperen.
Como parte de la internación en casa, organizamos recibir visitas en grupo.
Qué valiente fue Amy en recibirlos, aun cuando comenzaba su deterioro físico.
Una noche, los Krouse nos visitaron,
sus padres y tres hermanos,
y luego los amigos y la familia.
Cada uno contaba hermosas historias de Amy y de nosotros.
Amy produjo un gran impacto en sus leales amigos.
Pero la internación en la casa no es tan agradable para el resto de la familia.
Les contaré algo íntimo, y es que hasta el día de hoy
me asaltan los recuerdos de esas últimas semanas.
Recuerdo cuando caminaba hacia atrás en dirección al baño,
ayudando a Amy con cada paso.
Me sentía muy fuerte.
No soy un tipo tan grande,
pero mis brazos se veían y sentían muy fuertes
en comparación con el frágil cuerpo de Amy.
Y ese cuerpo se quebró en nuestra casa.
El 13 de marzo del año pasado,
mi esposa murió de cáncer de ovario en nuestra cama.
Llevé su cuerpo sin vida
por las escaleras,
crucé el comedor
hasta la sala de estar
y la puse en una camilla
que la trasladaría para ser cremada.
Nunca me quitaré esa imagen de la cabeza.
Si conocen a alguien que ha pasado por la experiencia
de la internación en casa, sabrán de qué hablo.
Solo díganles que escucharon a un tal Jason
hablar sobre lo difícil de sobrellevar esos recuerdos
y que estarán allí para escucharlos si desean hablar.
Es posible que no quieran hablar,
pero es bueno conectarse con alguien
que vive cada día con esas imágenes imborrables.
Sé que suena increíble, pero nunca me hicieron esa pregunta.
El escrito de Amy me hizo experimentar el dolor de una manera pública.
Muchos lectores me contactaron y escribieron bellas reflexiones.
El impacto causado por Amy tuvo un alcance más profundo y rico
de lo que incluso nosotros y su familia sabíamos.
Algunas de las respuestas que recibí
me ayudaron con el intenso proceso de duelo
por su humor,
como el correo electrónico de una mujer que leyó el artículo, donde decía:
"Me casaré contigo cuando estés preparado,
(Risas)
siempre y cuando dejes de beber para siempre.
No pongo otras condiciones.
Prometo vivir más años que tú.
Muchas gracias".
Ahora bien, me gusta un buen tequila, pero no es mi problema.
Sin embargo, ¿cómo podría decir que no a esa propuesta?
(Risas)
Lloré y reí al mismo tiempo al leer esta nota de un amigo de la familia:
"Recuerdo las cenas de Shabat en tu casa
y a Amy enseñándome a hacer crutones de pan de maíz.
Solo Amy podía ser creativa con los crutones".
(Risas)
El 27 de julio, a pocos meses de la muerte de Amy,
mi padre murió por las complicaciones
surgidas luego de décadas de lucha contra el Parkinson.
Y me pregunté: ¿cuánto puede soportar la condición humana?
¿Qué nos hace capaces de lidiar con esta pérdida intensa
y aun así continuar?
¿Era una prueba?
¿Por qué mi familia y mis increíbles hijos?
Buscar respuestas, lamento decir, es una misión de por vida,
pero la clave para poder perseverar
es el expreso mandato público de Amy que debo continuar.
A lo largo de este año, he hecho exactamente eso.
Intenté salir y buscar la alegría y la belleza
que sé que esta vida es capaz de proporcionar.
Pero la realidad es esta:
esas reuniones familiares, las bodas y eventos en honor a Amy
son grandes manifestaciones de cariño, pero muy difíciles de sobrellevar.
La gente dice que soy increíble.
"¿Cómo te manejas así en estos duros momentos?"
Dicen: "Lo haces con tanta entereza".
Pero, ¿saben qué?
En realidad, estoy triste la mayor parte del tiempo.
A menudo me siento confundido,
y sé que estos sentimientos aplican a otros cónyuges,
hijos,
padres
y demás familiares que pasan por un duelo.
En el zen japonés, hay un término, "shoji",
que se traduce como "nacimiento-muerte".
No hay separación tal entre la vida y la muerte
sino una línea delgada que las conecta.
El nacimiento, o la parte alegre, maravillosa y vital de la vida,
y la muerte, la parte que no queremos,
deben ser enfrentadas por igual.
En esta nueva vida que tengo,
hago lo posible para aplicar este concepto mientras avanzo en mi dolor.
Sin embargo, en los primeros meses tras la muerte de Amy,
estaba seguro de que la sensación de desesperación estaría siempre presente,
que me consumiría.
Pronto tuve la suerte de recibir algunos consejos alentadores.
Muchas personas que han perdido a su pareja me contactaron.
Una amiga que también había perdido a su compañero de vida me repetía:
"Jason, encontrarás alegría".
Ni siquiera sabía de qué estaba hablando.
¿Cómo era posible algo así?
Pero porque Amy me dio un permiso muy público
para encontrar la felicidad,
ahora siento alegría de vez en cuando.
Allí estaba, bailando toda la noche en un concierto de LCD Soundsystem,
viajando con mi hermano y mi mejor amigo
o con un compañero de la universidad, todos varones,
para conocer a un grupo de tipos maravillosos que nunca había escuchado.
Al observar el sol que daba sobre mi cubierta en un día frío,
allí tendido,
con el calor que abrasaba mi cuerpo,
la alegría viene de mis tres maravillosos hijos.
Estaba mi hijo Justin,
enviándome una foto con un caballero mayor
con un antebrazo macizo y fuerte y la leyenda, "Acabo de conocer a Popeye"
con una gran sonrisa en el rostro.
(Risas)
Estaba su hermano Miles, caminando hacia el tren
en su primer día de trabajo tras graduarse en la universidad,
quien se detuvo, me miró y preguntó:
"¿Qué estoy olvidando?"
Le aseguré de inmediato, "Estás 100 % listo. Lo tienes".
Y con mi hija Paris,
caminando juntos por Battersea Park en Londres,
las hojas amontonadas,
el sol brillando en la madrugada de nuestro camino hacia yoga.
Agregaría que la belleza también está allí por descubrirse,
y me refiero a la belleza de la variedad wabi-sabi,
pero belleza al fin.
Por un lado, cuando veo algo de este tipo, quiero decir:
"Amy, ¿viste eso? ¿Oíste eso?
Es demasiado hermoso para que no lo compartas conmigo".
Por otra parte,
ahora vivo estos momentos de una manera completamente nueva.
Está la belleza que encontré en la música,
como en el último álbum de la Orquesta de Manchester,
cuando la canción "The Alien"
hace una suave transición hacia "The Sunshine",
o la inquietante belleza del "Killing Me" de Luke Sital-Singh
cuyo estribillo dice,
"Y me está matando que no estés aquí conmigo.
Estoy viviendo feliz, pero me siento culpable".
Hay belleza en los momentos simples que la vida tiene para ofrecer,
una forma de ver ese mundo que era parte indisoluble del ADN de Amy,
como en mi viaje diario por la mañana,
mirando el sol que se refleja en el lago Michigan,
o deteniéndome a ver cómo brilla la luz
en diferentes momentos del día
en la casa que construimos juntos;
incluso tras una tormenta en Chicago, contemplando la nieve recién caída
en todo el vecindario;
o asomándome a la habitación de mi hija
mientras ella practica el bajo.
Quiero dejar en claro que soy una persona muy afortunada.
Tengo la familia más increíble, que me ama y me apoya.
Tengo recursos para el crecimiento personal durante mi proceso de duelo.
Pero ya sea un divorcio,
la pérdida de un trabajo por el que se esforzaron tanto
o la muerte de un familiar, sea repentina, o lenta y dolorosa,
me gustaría ofrecerles
lo que yo recibí:
un espacio en blanco en una hoja de papel.
¿Qué harían con ese espacio vacío intencional,
con ese nuevo comienzo?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)